before i killed her
but at the kasim outpost then they must
be holding the empty the only chance we
have direct shira
of the iron wolves
the emperor and my friend are in grave
danger i must gain
i heard what you did at kasim outpost
and now captain ravan
this woman has vital information very
well let them pass
let's go i'll lead you to the palace
you are bold to have stopped this
audience with me my gods tell me you
were responsible for the massacre of
innocent villagers in arkanis
do not believe those lies alcarnus was
the work of magda
and her coven who served belial
if you are innocent then why do you have
a spy
skulking through my sewers bring her in
let me go i detest
violence gods i'll leave this matter in
your hands
let us leave before more guards arrived
[Music]
get out of here i will cover your escape
thank you
now you need to get the sewers i'll
explain
more fuel
no way these demons are blocking our way
we must destroy their summoning
it's
conflict
i expected more
there has to be a way into the sewers
from here this leads to the sewers
she's alive but the imperial guard is
holding her somewhere down here